this video is sponsored by health
journey support a free website where
patients can learn to manage chronic
diseases by watching 3d animations
please visit health journey support com
to learn more
you or someone you care about may have
been diagnosed with lung cancer this
video will help you understand more
about lung cancer and how it affects
your body
your lungs are a pair of organs inside
your chest that allow you to breathe you
inhale oxygen which all cells need then
you exhale a waste gas called carbon
dioxide
this gas exchange has
inside tiny air sacs in your lungs lung
cancer is a disease in which normal lung
cells change into harmful abnormal cells
called cancer cells cancer cells
multiply to form clusters called tumors
these tumors grow and destroy healthy
lung tissue
lung cancer may spread to other parts of
your body through blood or lymph fluid a
natural substance that helps gather
unwanted waste material from your body
there are two main types of lung cancer
small cell lung cancer and non small
cell lung cancer they are named for the
kinds of cells in the cancer and how
they look under a microscope non small
cell lung cancer is the most common type
of lung cancer small cell lung cancer is
the most aggressive type of lung cancer
it grows and spreads more quickly
the most important risk factor for lung
cancer is smoking
other risk factors include breathing
secondhand smoke exposure to radon
having a family history of lung cancer
HIV infection exposure to harmful
chemicals such as asbestos
and air pollution
lung cancer may have no symptoms in its
early stages
and symptoms do up here they may include
chronic cough chest pain trouble
breathing coughing up blood hoarseness
loss of appetite trouble swallowing
weight loss tiredness and facial or neck
swelling
if you have lung cancer your doctor will
need to determine the stage or
progression of the disease to help plan
your treatment non-small-cell lung
cancer has many stages in the occult
stage cancer cells are found only in
lung fluids in stage 0 abnormal or
cancer cells are found in the lining of
the airways by stage 1 a small tumor is
found
then in stage two the cancer has grown
or spread to nearby lymph nodes or non
lung tissues in stage three a the tumor
has grown to any size
in addition cancer is found in lymph
nodes on the same side of the chest or
in nearby organs stage 3b is similar to
3a but in 3b cancer is found in lymph
nodes on the opposite side of the chest
cancer may also be found in lymph nodes
above the collarbone in stage four
tumours might be found in both lungs
additionally cancer may have spread to
distant organs there are fewer stages
for small cell lung cancer
in its limited stage cancer is found in
one side of the chest only in the
extensive stage cancer has spread to the
other side of the chest or to distant
organs
as you deal with a diagnosis of lung
cancer continue to talk to your doctor
and your cancer care team